you can't have our children being
exposed to things that are going to harm
them and that we don't agree with his
parents like for instance you had just
recently balenciagas it's very famous
brand and then they had in their ad they
had a child dressed in bondage and then
they had a document all these
subliminals you would think this is some
kind of conspiracy it's like they're
showing you right in front of your face
and then they had a court document of a
pedophilia case then you have another
other now Andrew he's talking about it
it was done on purpose which as we've
just deciphered it must have been what
do you think the reaction should be for
Muslims it should form coalitions of the
imams long bit Interfaith Partners to
amplify our voice there should be
alliances of psychologists alliances of
the medical doctors all of these
alliances should be there because there
are so many people out there who are
thinking the same way we are thinking
but they may not know how to start where
to start